can you talk more about the fears you
had and
how did you know they weren't really
fears when it came to your writing
especially when you were starting out
that's interesting because really i
believe
they were fears i think that the things
that people are afraid of
in writing they should be afraid of you
know you should
and if if you're expecting to make a
living as a writer and you're afraid
that you won't that's a very legitimate
fear because the odds are you won't
and in fact i think one of the most
important things that i would advise
is plan for the thing you fear
if you're really afraid that you won't
make a living as a writer and you want
to be a writer
start to plan for how you're going to be
a writer when you don't make a living at
it because i ran into that
often even after i was a professional
writer because even when you're a
professional
in the union a highly paid writer
it can dry up it can go away things can
change
and the important thing that you want to
do is think first of all would i stop
writing
if i couldn't make a living at it if so
i don't know that you're going to be a
very happy and be a writer because
you you need to be able to want to do it
no matter what
and then okay so i will
be a writer and work early in the
morning before my job as a pharmacist or
i will
be a writer and be as i was an office
temp for 12 years or i will be a writer
and live with my family for the rest of
my life whatever it is you know there's
no
right or wrong way to do this there's no
actual
path and so you've got to figure out
what makes sense for you
and one of the most important things
about that is to recognize
what you're afraid of and try and plan
for the reality of it if it's going it
could happen
you know and and i think that that
actually is what helps a lot is to say
well
all right if i don't make it in
hollywood would i still keep writing
and the answer should be yes it may not
be i keep writing scripts or maybe i'll
write scripts for podcasts that i can
produce myself
or i'll write for theater or i'll make
graphic novels whatever it's going to be
face the fear and be realistic about it
um that that was actually what got me
through
um that that big fear am i going to be
able to do this
there there are so many fears to being
an artist aren't there because i was
just thinking
that's one but then there's the fear of
am i any good
maybe i'm not good enough and once again
the answer has to be well you're going
to be as good as you're going to be
i mean being afraid of it is not going
to make you better
so you might as well just be how you are
and see where that lands you
um you can't actually change many things
there's a lot of things that make it
easier or harder for each of us and
every one of us is different and for me
the fear of you know will this be
accepted will this be liked at a certain
point it's probably better to look at
that fear and say
would i keep writing this even if
everyone hated it and if you can find
something that you would write then
that's probably the thing you should
write
find a way to do the thing that you
do no matter what um
that's that the because the rest of the
fears for most of us like nobody's going
to cut your hands off if you write badly
you know
i mean except in certain places probably
right
but hopefully for those of us who are
not living there
um you know it's
these are nice problems to have and
artists should
take a deep breath and recognize that
you know
the the worst thing that could happen is
you don't make a fortune
oh gee you know if you write operas or
poems you
would never even occur to you
screenwriters have this weird idea
that they're supposed to be rich and
famous that is not actually an
artist's lot most 99.9
of screenwriters are not rich and famous
99 of
working screenwriters are not even rich
you know it's it's
and certainly in the the scale of what
we think of as that
percentage of of that's what a
screenwriter is
um most screenwriters don't get to
choose what they work on
um and and honestly what you're doing is
balancing you're saying
i want to get paid for writing but i
also want to
write what's in my head well you're not
going to get to do both of those most of
the time
if you write what's in your like i wrote
i was a working screenwriter for
25 years and non-stop great jobs
exciting i almost was never writing a
project that i
conceived of i was being hired by people
who wanted my talents and my skills
for their project and that was paying
the rent and
you know the best day job you'll ever
have and some of the most wonderful
experiences i've ever had
but at the i was not writing what i
could imagine
so i had to do that on the side almost
none of those projects went
anywhere people would read them and say
wow that's great we can't make that
so you know that's success
that's you know is that is that the
picture that you all have out there of
your success no everyone has the success
picture of those two or three writers
that we see interviewed
who are like oh yeah well i decided i
was going to do this project and i
called them up and i told them i was
doing it and they gave me a million
dollars and i went and wrote it
that's just not how that's you know
that's winning the lottery that's
getting
hit by lightning being born into the
royal family you know
if if you're lucky enough that that
happens great but most of us should
plan for the thing we fear
and were your fears greater at that time
to make a living as a writer or would
you even get another temp job because
you know with the damping
sometimes you don't know if you're going
to be working from week to week or
hi we don't need you anymore and you're
like okay did i do something you know
and
which fear was greater at that time
that's actually a great question because
it brings up the issue of
sustainability um and by which i do not
mean
you know we recycle our projects i mean
you have to be able to have a
sustainable life
to be an artist a creative person of any
type and so you need to be able to
separate those
and say i need to deal with the fear of
not paying the rent and not having food
and not having a good relationship and
all those
life things that are very important they
have
nothing to do with your work and your
work should not
be making the save on those you should
not be saying
i have a crappy relationship but one day
i'm going to be such a famous writer
that they'll love
me anyway that's a bad plan have a good
life
and then write have a life that you can
live
whether or not you ever become a rich
and famous writer and
and if that is a small life good
whatever as long as it's a sustainable
life as long as you can
take care of yourself then you can apply
yourself
to the process of writing an artist
they're an artistic problem the problems
of am i good enough is this meaningful
enough
all those things let alone will it make
any money which is not
really entirely an artistic problem is a
separate thing that you do
when you have the space and the health
to do it
you first have to take care of yourself
you have to have
a place to live and a routine by which
you can live
fairly reliably and hopefully with some
good mental health
take care of that first don't be in debt
don't put off all the things of your
life
until you you know oh i'll i'll take
care of that when i'm
when i'm successful um no one's ever
successful enough
to take care of that that has to come
first
and then you make a space for your work
and you'll deal with each artistic
problem like
what is this scene about or is this a
good idea
that i feel like committing a year to
those are artistic problems
but they have nothing to do they
shouldn't be
how you decide whether or not you're
going to pay your rent
if you get lucky i mean honestly once
you know if you get into the union and
you become a professional writer
you're still basically not going to be
asking that question you're going to be
asking how do i get this job that
someone else has done the creative work
on and i want to work on their project
because except for a small teeny number
of people who are show runners
or people who are writing features which
is a very small number now
you're mostly working on a staff that's
a job
it's a job at a corporation a great job
but often a great corporation and it's
really cool
but it's not an artistic problem
um artistic problems should be solved
with artistic things
and life problems should be definitely
solved with life things not with
artistic solutions
you